pour plusieurs chercheurs une meilleure
gestion de risque est vraiment la clé
pour éviter les dommages qui sont liées
à toutes ces inondations et pour y
parvenir certains se tournent vers
l'intelligence artificielle on m'a parlé
avec notre journaliste scientifique
renault manuguerra gagner alors renault
dites nous à quoi
et de quelle façon en fait
l'intelligence artificielle peut
vraiment servir dans des dans la gestion
de crises d'inondations mais ça pourrait
avoir un rôle énorme dans la
planification avant pendant et après la
crise parce que la gestion de risques
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
important quand on fait face à des
catastrophes comme les inondations
mais pour mieux s'y préparer il faut
qu'on ait de meilleurs modèles et pour
ça il ya plusieurs chercheurs qui se
tourne vers l'intelligence artificielle
parce que c'est un outil qui excelle
dans les situations qui ont une énorme
quantité de variables est ce c'est
souvent ça qu'on fait face quand on est
quand on a des preuves dans des
catastrophes environnementales et donc
des outils qui aident à mieux préparer
les risques que ça va aider à mieux nous
préparer et à mieux voir comment vont
ils réagir donc c'est pour ça que c'est
un outil qui pourrait être très
important dans l'avenir
bon et comment les scientifiques ont
soif ces outils mais donc pour saler les
algorithmes donc ça c'est les chaînes de
calcul que les intelligences
artificielles utilisent pour répondre à
certaines questions mais les algorithmes
les autres sont ils excellent avoir des
tendances donc à détecter qu'est ce qui
relie différents éléments les uns aux
autres mais pour ça il faut qu'on ait
beaucoup de données qui vont venir de
satellites qui ont eu d'informations sur
le terrain ou de cartes et donc l'été
les gens à la façon dont on conçoit ses
programmes l'a d'abord il faut évaluer
la dénivellation du sol de façon
extrêmement précise qu'une cartographie
les bassins versants
ça va permettre de mieux estimer ou
l'eau risquent de se retrouver si jamais
on arrive en situation d'inondation
l'autre élément pour une fois qu'on a ça
il faut qu'on le combino données météo
qu'on a eues durant qu'ont eue les
données récentes
donc la quantité de neige qu'on a eues
durant l'hiver leur fonte la pluie
conviction des venets que ce soit des
données accessibles à plus con au
printemps avec tout ça les algorithmes
capables de se perfectionner de ce que
régis jusqu'à ce qu'ils permettent de
prévoir de façon très précise
qu'est ce qui va arriver dans une banque
en cas d'inondations majeures sur des
cartes du territoire on n'est pas rendus
exactement à l'heure l'intelligence
artificielle est pas prête à être
déployée à grande échelle sur le terrain
en temps de crise mais beaucoup de
chercheurs qui travaillent et beaucoup
d'autres outils informatiques peuvent
être très utiles dans ces situations là
qu'est ce que ça pourrait aider
à faire concrètement mais d'abord des
modèles plus précis ça pourrait d'abord
nous aide à nous préparer en amont donc
en sachant qu est ce qui pourrait se
passer quelques jours d'avancé ce serait
possible par exemple d'envoyer du
personnel et l'équipement de façon
préventive pour réagir plus rapidement
et décider quelle on doit vraiment été
évacués une fois que les crues ont
commencé please on est dans les
inondations d'autres algorithmes pour
aider à suivre la montée des eaux en
temps réel et ça comme ça au lieu
d'avoir des risques de d'inondations
généralise on pourrait dire de façon
plus précise t-elle quartier va avoir
une hausse de trois pieds d'eau alors
que tel autre attention ça va être neuf
pieds donc ça ça change de beaucoup les
phases de la façon dont on va réagir et
des municipalités des universités qui
travaille là dessus et aussi des grandes
compagnies qui ont mais microsoft avait
bien mais gogos qui sont en train
d'élaborer ce genre de système là qui
pourrait aussi venir sur la forme
d'applications dont les promesses sont
assez grande et un autre élément qui est
important à dire c'est qu'une bonne
partie de la crise actuelle elle est
liée à la construction de différentes
habitations en zone inondable ce on en a
beaucoup parlé et c'est quelque chose
qu'on a qu'on a beaucoup fait au
détriment la conservation de certaines
régions humides qui elles sont connues
pour absorber l'excès d'eau donc en
gardant cette idée l'en-tête une
intelligence artificielle pourrait mieux
décider quelle région on aurait le droit
de constater que reconstruire
quelle autre région faute il ne faut pas
il faut interdire de reconstruction et
ou déplacer certaines installations
mais ce qui est important disque pour ça
il faut de l'information précise et ces
dernières années on s'est rendu compte
que plusieurs secteurs qui avait pas de
cartes de zones inondables ou qu'elle
était avec quelques décennies de retard
donc pour ça il faut vraiment qu'on
réussisse à les actualiser way que
toutes les banques de données soient à
jour merci beaucoup un autre est
intéressant ça fait plaisir